for the first time since the pandemic
began Dr fauci is finally speaking the
truth allegedly the nation's top doc
admitting this about his draconian
lockdowns
when you're dealing with a situation
where the hospitals were being overrun
in New York
intensive care units were being put in
hallways you have to do something that's
rather Draconian and sometimes when you
do Draconian things it does have
deleterious consequences on the economy
on the school children you know that but
you have to make a balance
there you go smirin the draconians again
how racist
anyway thanks to fauci teachers unions
those school closures erased two decades
of students progress in math and reading
two decades I didn't know that and
speaking of teachers unions leader Randy
Weingarten blasting Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis saying it's his fault kids
aren't thriving
we would ask the governor
instead of smearing teachers instead of
calling them names
roll up your sleeves and work with us to
actually help kids Thrive the people who
are standing behind me
they want to teach kids
they want to make a difference in kids
lives
they didn't come into teaching
to be demagogued to be dehumanized to be
smeared oh to do your job for God's sake
Dana yes what do you make of fauci seems
very defensive well the media tours
continue and I've always said that he
probably would benefit himself if he did
less media right um I've said that for
I've said that for a long time so that
to him when he was on my show in the
middle of an interview is that you
really should stop doing so much of this
uh you know
everyone at the beginning
signed off on the lockdowns even
reluctantly exactly right now I think
what happened is the public health
experts were then allowed to go way
beyond their jurisdiction because as I
feel this is how I feel it should work
public health expert comes in and says
Mr President Mrs president whoever it is
in the future uh here's what we have
this is the situation this is what we
are recommending and if we do this XYZ
will happen if you do that ABC will
happen that's our opinion but now we
turn it over to you the elected leader
of the people of the United States and
then you get to decide because you're
the one that balances the risk and makes
the decision based on that so we got
away from that and you knew that right
away when the schools were continuing to
be closed but we had new information the
new information said kids aren't
spreading it kids aren't getting sick
kids are falling behind in school nobody
can deal with the zoom classes and they
didn't change anything for two years
that's why Randy Weingarten is out there
blaming DeSantis when he actually opened
the school so I think the parents can
figure that one out and the other thing
was not just on businesses so it was
very strange why was it that Home Depot
could be open but the small mom-and-pop
hardware stores had to be closed and it
became
unfair and outrageous and it's it's left
a bad taste there were so many mistakes
Jessica I think across the board a lot
of people made mistakes but to to Dana's
point is this something where people
when you have a lockdown people didn't
want to unlock it because if something
bad were to happen then they would be
responsible for the so there was a lot
of kind of cowardice and covering your
ass kind of mentality and all of these
bureaucrats a hundred percent they were
going to be blamed for whatever happened
if it did go wrong and now they're
getting blamed for what happened when it
did go wrong it was just the kind of
wrong that we didn't think was going to
happen in the first place you know this
idea that kids are going to be fine
they're resilient children are resilient
but we know that they do need Social and
emotional connections with people that
they need to be interacting they need to
be in classrooms they need to see faces
that's one of the strongest arguments
against everyone's being masked in these
environments and now even the most
liberal schools are saying that kids can
take off their masks and it's up to the
parents to choose what they want to do
with them
um we've been presented with a lot of
trade-offs remember when it was you know
you don't need a mass but the truth was
that we didn't have enough masks and
people need to people in elected
positions bureaucratic positions need to
treat us like adults people can make
these decisions for themselves we all
take calculated risks no matter what
we're doing in the day crossing the
street is a calculated risk when we're
going to leave the building after this
especially now
um anyway we're running out of time but
this is something that is going to be
pushed back against teachers obviously
and pouchy well this is going to go on
forever judge the constant why can't he
just like Let It Go retire go away go
play does he play golf I don't know I
don't know you know he doesn't play
baseball
um look I mean I'm tired of hearing from
him I'm tired and I think everybody's
tired of hearing him try to justify what
he did and and then on top of it you've
got this like sandwich where Randy
Weingarten is trashing Rhonda santis and
saying you know you should be working
with us no Randy you got the money you
should have opened the schools
um and the census was showing the
country how Florida could open the
schools and the Catholic schools the
religious schools and the charter
schools that were all open
um and I I just think that this back and
forth and and you know everybody's kind
of tired of it fauci doesn't have
credibility and part of the reason is
that a decision was made to listen to
fauci as opposed to doing something like
a men Manhattan Project where we brought
in the best of the best as opposed to a
guy who's been there for 40 years who
makes all kinds of money who's invested
in all kinds of drugs who was involved
in gang of function uh funding I mean
this is not the guy we shouldn't have
been that we should have been listening
to and that's the that's the one thing
that I Come Away with he was the wrong
guy and we should never rely on the one
guy I mean certainly in the end the
president made the decision but there
should have been a group a panel of
experts so Jesse why doesn't he just
shut up and write a book yes isn't he I
think I'm assuming so the people of the
tidbits for the book yeah the book will
be out right when he leaves office so he
doesn't have to face the Republican
Congress Randy's a Viper isn't she isn't
she a vicious woman if you're supposed
to be all about the children wouldn't
you want to work with every governor and
that Governor down there in Florida he
did right by the students that the
Florida students probably did the best
of any of the students he didn't shut
down any of the schools and then he let
the parents decide whether not they were
going to mask or not so fauci also took
two positions on the lockdowns he told
Cavuto
four weeks ago that he doesn't regret
any of the lockdowns and the school
closures did not harm the kids and now
he comes out and says yeah the school
closure is kind of hard on the kids you
think you can't isolate a six or seven
or eight year old for two years when
they're going through that developmental
stage where their learning how to be
social and how to relate to people
psychologically these people are scarred
for life not to mention all the people
that died from suicide and Drug
overdoses I mean the guy should be sued
by every child in the country class
action child abuse
I worked at pro bono even though I don't
even have a law degree I don't think you
need one I don't I don't think your
skill I think your your skills are
enough if I was charged with a crime I
would defend myself I think you should I
think to prove it I think I know I think
to prove that you should go commit a
crime and then defend yourself I'll be
right back yeah thank you kill meets
right out there just okay all right all
right up next the latest Act of liberal
City depravity depravity a homeless man
caught on camera throwing poop at people
I went on Brian Kilmeade I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now